we don't agree that almighty God has to
come in this world and become a human
being this philosophy of almighty God
becoming a human being is called as
anthropomorphism which many religions
believe in this philosophy that almighty
God became a human being and they have a
logic for that what they say that
almighty God Is So holy he's so pure he
does not know the shortcomings of the
human being how does the human being
feel when he's hurt how does the human
being feel when he's in trouble
how does the human being feel when you
got problems so that's the reason
Almighty became a human being so that he
could set the rules the dos and don'ts
for the human beings on the face of it
it sounds like a good logic almighty God
so holy so pure he does not know the
shortcoming of the human beings
therefore to set the rules he became a
human
being I'm asking a simple question let's
suppose I manufacture a VCR a video
cassette recorder do I have to become a
VCR a video CET recorder to know what is
good or what is bad for the
VCR if I manufacture a VCR since I'm the
manufacturer since I'm the Creator I
don't have to become a VCR to know what
is good or what is bad for the VCR what
do I do I write an instruction manual
that if you want to play the video
cassette insert the cassette and press
the play button if you want to stop you
press the stop button if you want to
fast forward press the FF button don't
drop it from a height it will get
spoiled don't imers it in water it will
get damaged I write an instruction
manual I don't have to become a VCR to
know what is good or what is bad for the
VCR if I've created the VCR similarly
almighty God since he's the creator of
the human beings he doesn't have to
become a human being to know what is
good or what is bad for the human being
what does he do he chooses a man amongst
men and communicates with them on a
higher level who we call as
Messengers and he reveals this
instruction manual to guide the
humankind and the last and final
instruction manual of almighty God it is
the Glorious Quran the dos and don'ts
for the human being is mentioned in the
last and fin instruction manual of the
human beings that is the Glorious
Quran so the isamic concept perfectly
matches with the concept of The Vedas it
may not match with the common Hindus who
believe that almighty God becomes a
human being but nowhere does the Veda
has the concept that almighty God has
become a human being it has a concept
that almighty God has sent Ries has sent
people who were close to almighty God so
that they could guide the
humankind and there are mentions of
several
rishes and Messengers in the
vdas let us discuss what do the Hindu
scriptures have to speak about the last
and final messenger Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon
him it's mentioned in the bisha purana
par
3 ad 3as 10 to
27 it says that the malayas have spoiled
the land of the
Arabs AR is not to be found
there there was enemy who I defeated
earlier but now he has been sent by a
more powerful enemy I will send a man by
the name of Muhammad peace be upon him
who will destroy these enemies and will
guide the people to the true path oh
Raja
you need not go to the land of the
pachas for I through my kindness will
purify you here itself a man in the
angel disposition he appears in front of
Raja and says oh Raja I have been sent
by ishwar
patma Arya D will prevail the religion
of trth will prevail in the world I have
been sent by iswar patma to enforce a
Creed of of meat
eaters my follower shall be a person who
is
circumcised who does not have a shendy
on his
head who has created a revolution who
keeps a
beard who gives the call for prayer who
eats all lawful thing but will not have
the Flesh of swine he will not be
purified by hubs and shs but will be
purified by w
he will be called a musalman he will be
a me teacher now this prophecy about a
Rishi to come the name of the Rishi is
mentioned as Muhammad peace be upon him
and it says that he will guide the
people on the straight path and we know
mhammad sallallahu Ali wasallam guided
the Arabs it was known as yah the days
of ignorance he guided them to
light and say that his follower will be
a person who circumcised and the Muslims
are circumcised he will not have a
shendi will not have a tail on the head
and we Muslims don't have who will grow
a beard we Muslims grow a beard we'll
create a revolution we give the call for
prayer that is the Adan and we Muslims
we give the Adan that the call for
prayers they will eat all lawful things
but will not touch the Flesh of swine
and we Muslims we don't eat porke they
will not be purified by hubs and shes
but we'll be purified by Warfare and we
have been told in the Quran that we have
to fight for the truth against AR in
operation they will be called musalman
they will be meat
eaters this prophecy in bhavisha purana
clearly specifies about the last and
final messenger Prophet Muhammad
sallallah Ali wasallam and his followers
as Muslims have been described he has
been prophesized in several places time
will not permit I'll just give a
reference to the few of the bhishan he's
also prophesied in bisha purana 3 K 3
ADH 3as 5 to8 he even prophesied in
bhavish 3 1H 3as 21-23
the last and final messenger has also
been prophesied in the in book number 20
him number 127 Mantra number 1 to4 these
are called as K suas kup in Sanskrit
means the hidden gland in the abdomen
indicating that the meaning of these
verses the hidden they'll be known
later and time will not permit to
discuss all the 14 mantas we'll just
discuss the Salient feature of the first
four mantras mantra number one says he
is narash shansa he is Kama who will
defeat 6,90
enemies man number two says he is a
camel riding Rishi man number three says
he's Mama Rishi man number four says
he's w r the first Mantra says he is
narash shansa narash shansa is derived
from Nar which means a man or a person
and shansa as we know prashansa means
praise so narash shansa means one who is
praiseworthy and if you
translate the name of the last and final
messenger Muhammad sallallahu Ali
wasallam into English if you translate
Muhammad into English s wasallam it
means the praiseworthy so narash shansa
is the exact translation of the Arabic
name Muhammad sallallah Ali wasallam so
it's mentioned my
name further it says that he is Kama one
of the meaning of Kama in Sanskrit is
Prince of Peace and the prophet M Sall
Ali wasallam was the Prince of Peace the
other meaning is an immigrant and
Muhammad sallallahu Al wasallam migrated
from Makkah to Madina he was an
immigrant first Mantra also says he will
defeat 6,90 enemies an approximate
population of the people of Makkah who
are against Prophet mmad sallallah Ali
wasallam was approximately
60,000 Mantra number two says he will be
a camel riding Rishi no Indian Rishi no
Brahman will ever ride a camel because
according to Manus smiti chapter number
11 verse number 202 it says a Brahman is
forbidden to ride a donkey or a camel so
this indicates it cannot be a Indian
Rishi manra number three says he's Mama
Rishi Mama comes from Maha meaning great
Rishi and some of the other scripture
also say is Muhammad Rishi Mantra number
four says he's r r means one who praises
and the other name of Muhammad sallallah
Ali wasallam was Ahmed
which if you translate into English it
means the one who praises so even his
other name that is Ahmed translated into
Sanskrit is mentioned in
the so these
mantras they clearly specify no one but
the last and final messenger Prophet
Muhammad sallallah Ali
wasallam I will just mention a few other
prophecies there are several Muhammad
sallahu Ali wasallam has even been
prophesized in book number 20 him number
21 verse number 6 it says that
akaru he will defeat 10,000 enemies
without a fight it is talking about
Battle of aab the battle of K chapter
number 33 in the Quran and Karu in
Sanskrit means the one who praise which
is another translation of the second
name of Muhammad sallallah Al wasallam
Ahmed the one who praises it says this
person one who praises that is Ahmed he
will defeat 10,000 en without a fight
and we know in the battle of kandak the
enemies were approximate 10,000 in
number and the battle was won without a
fight taking place he also prophesized
in book number 20 himym number 21 verse
number 7 it says that the Abu he will
defeat 6,90 enemies and the 20 Chiefs
Abu in Sanskrit again means one who
praises that is a translation of the
name Muhammad Sall Al wasallam it also
say that he'll been orphan
and we know today from history that
there were approximately 20 Chiefs of
Makkah which were defeated mammad Salli
wasallam and the population of Makkah
against the prophet was approximately
60,000 this prophecy is also repeated in
rig book number one himym number 53
verse number n but the Sanskrit word is
suama suama in the Sanskrit dictionary
again it means one who praises which is
the translation of the name Muhammad
sallah Ali
wasallam there are various prophecies
time will not permit us to go into the
detail he's also prophesied in the
Sam in ut Mantra number 1,500 it says
that Ahmed has been given the Eternal
law he is mentioned by name also as aham
s wasallam he has been given the Eternal
law that is the Glorious Quran that is
the
Shar but if you read the translation of
this verse because ahammad is Arabic
word they could not translate it so they
thought it was and and mati in Sanskrit
means my father so it says my father has
given me eternal law so the translation
if you read it differs but the original
script mentions the word Ahmed and the
word Ahmed is even mentioned in other
plac in Hindu scriptures including Sam
with Indra chapter number two Mantra
152 he's even mentioned as Ahmed in j CH
number 31 verse number 18 in rig book
Number 8 himym number 6 verse number 10
he's also prophesized by name Ahmed
Ina book number eight hymn number five
verse number 16 as well as book number
20 hymn number 126 Mantra number
14 Prophet Muhammad sallallahu Ali
wasallam besides being mentioned as
Ahmed one of his names he's also
mentioned as narash
in several places in the Hindu
scriptures and as I mentioned earlier
that narash shansa is derived from Nar
which means a man or person and shansa
which means prashansa praiseworthy so
narash shansa means a person who's
praiseworthy that is exact translation
of the name of the last and final
messenger Muhammad Salli wasallam into
English he is mentioned by narash shansa
several places in the Hindu scriptures
in r book number one himym number 13
verse number three rig book number one
hymn number 18 verse number n rade book
number one hymn number 106 verse number
four rig book number one him number 142
verse number three rig book number two
him number three verse number two rade
book number five hymn number five verse
number
[Applause]
two rig book number seven hymn number
two verse number two rig book number 10
hymn number 64 verse number 3 rig book
number 10 hymn number 182 verse number
two yaj chapter number 21 verse number
31 vaj chapter number 21 verse number 55
J chapter number 20 verse number 37 J
chapter number 20 verse number 57 J
chapter number 28 verse number two yaj
chapter number 28 verse number 19 yaj
chapter number 28 verse number
42 you can keep on quoting only the
references where Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him has been mentioned by name
as narash shansa in several places in
the Hindu
scriptures you can give a talk for days
together only on Prophecies of Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam in the Hindu
scriptures I will just mention one more
last prophecy about the
kar and he's been prophesied as
Kar in the bhagat
purana 12 ad 2 shlokas 18 to 20 it says
that he will be born in House of Vishnu
Yas a noble sold Brahman who's the chief
of the village of
sambala
and he will be called as the
Ki Mantra number 19 and 20 says that he
will be the Supreme lord of the
worlds he'll be given superal knowledge
and character and will be given eight
special characteristics eight special
qualities he will be given a steed a
horse by the angels and he will ride a
horse carrying a sword in his hand and
he will defeat the enemies and he'll be
helped by the angels He further
prophesies in bhagat
Pana K one three
25 that he'll be born in the
kug this Kar be born in kalyug in which
the Kings will behave like
robbers and he'll be born in the house
of Vishnu Yas and will be called as
Ki same Kar is even mentioned in the Ki
purana in chapter number two verse
number four which says that he will be
born in the house of Vishnu
Yas kipana chapter number two verse
number five says he will be helped by
four
companions in spreading his
religion kipana chapter number two verse
number 7 it says that he'll be helped by
the angels in the battlefield kipana
chapter number 2 verse number 11 says
that he will be born in the house of
Vishnu yes in the womb of
suti and K chapter number 2 verse number
15 says he'll be born in the first half
of mad month you can only give a talk on
Kar I'll just mention the points in
brief that these prophecies what do they
say Point number one that it says that
the name of ki's father will be Vishnu
Yas Vishnu Yas if you translate means
the worship of Vishnu worshipper of God
and the name of Muhammad sallallah
alam's father was Abdullah which also
means worshipper of Allah worshipper of
God Point number
two the name of the mother of kar will
be SU
suti if you translate into English it
means peace and the name of mam s mother
was Amina which you translate into
English me
PE further says that he will be born in
the village by the name of samala
sambala if you translate means a place
of Serenity and peace and similarly
Muhammad sallallahu Al wasallam born in
Makkah it was known as the DAR the place
of peace and
serenity so it is also mentioned that
he'll be born in Makkah it further says
he'll be born In The House of the chief
of sambala House of the chief of Makkah
which we know mamad sallah Ali wasallam
was born that he was born in the house
of the chief of Makkah born in the quray
family it further says that he will be
born on the 12th day of the first half
of the month of mad and we know Muhammad
sallallahu Ali wasallam was born in the
first half of the Luna month of r on the
12th
day this prophecy that he was born on
the 12th day of mad is the same as 12th
day of
RAB further it says that this
Kar he will be a final messenger exactly
what mentioned in the Quran inah chapter
number 33 verse number 40 where it
says which means that Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon Him is not the father of
any of you men but is the messenger of
Allah and he is the Seal of the prophets
the final messenger
Allah is all knowing full of knowledge
further it says that this Kar he will
get Knowledge from Pam that's from
almighty God in a mountain and we know
mhamad sallahu Ali wasallam the first
revelation he got in G ja the Mount of n
in G and prophecy further says that he
will go towards north and come back and
we know Muhammad sallallah Ali wasallam
migrated from Makkah northward toward
Madina and he came back to Makkah
victoriously
further it says that
this he will be an example to the whole
world he'll have an impeccable character
as Allah says in the Quran in Surah
Kalam chapter number 68 verse number
four that verily thou art standeth on
the highest standard of
character it's further mentioned he'll
be given eight special qualities and in
kipana and bhagwat purana the eight
qualities mentioned is wisdom
self-control
respectable
lineage reveal knowledge
Valor
charity
gratefulness and measured speech and the
prophet Muhammad sallallah Ali wasallam
was known for all these eight qualities
furthermore it's mentioned he will be a
teacher of the world as Allah says in
the Quran in Surah Sabah chapter 34
Verse number
28 that we have sent thee not but as a
universal messenger giving glad Tiding
and warning them against sin but most of
the human beings that do not know it
further says that this Kar he'll be
given a
Ste by almighty God and we know muhamad
s Al wasallam was given the Bak by which
he did the M that the Ascension to the
heavens it further says this K will ride
a horse and will carry a sword and we
know mammad sallallah Ali wasallam he
took part in most of the battles most of
them which are fought in self-defense
and even though he was a leader he
physically took part he rode the horse
and even caught the sword in the right
hand further the prophecy says that
he'll be held by four companions to
spread the religion the de and we know
it refers to the four khalifas the
rash AB Bakr
Umar Ali may Allah be pleas with them
all who later became the rashin rightly
guided khalifas of Islam who spread the
religion further It also says that this
he defeat the enemy and guide the people
to the right track and you know Muhammad
sallallahu Ali wasallam defeated the
enemies and he guided the Arabs from y
Jah the of ignorance he guided them to
the true part and the final Point
mention is that he will be helped by the
angels in the battlefield and we know
Muhammad saham was held by angels in
several battles including the Battle of
bad which is mentioned in the Quran in
Surah Imran chapter number 3: 123 to 125
as well as Surah anal chapter number 8
verse number 8 and 9 so this prophecy
ofar the last and final messenger befits
no one but the last and final messenger
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
me the fifth pillar of
Iman is life after death that here after
first we'll
discuss the life after that Hinduism and
then Islam
the common Hindu or most of the Hindus
they believe in the cycle of birth death
rebirth death rebirth known as the
samsara it's also called as the theory
of reincarnation or transmigration of
soul and this philosophy of
samsara it came about
because the scholars they could not
justify that how could almighty God be
unjust that some human beings are born
wealthy some human beings they born poor
some human beings they have been given
Health some have got diseases so
almighty God cannot be unjust therefore
they came with this philosophy of
samsara based on the verse of bhagwad
Gita chapter number two verse number
22 it says that as a human being he
changes and throws away the old clothes
and wear new clothes similarly the soul
throws away the old material body and
puts on the new
body a similar message is given in bhar
upanishad part four chapter number four
verse number three it says that whenever
caterpillar climbs onto a grass of Blade
he jumps onto a new blade similarly a
soul takes a new body So based on these
verses of bhagwat
Gita and the upanishad the scholars to
justify they had this theory of samsara
cycle of birth death rebirth and they
believe in the concept of Karm that is
action action not only of the body but
action even of the Soul based on the
philosophy as you SW so shall you reap
whatever you s you shall reap
they believe also in Dharma Dharma means
deed righteous deed how you live your
life family life life in society if your
K is based on D you'll have good Karm
and they also believe in Moka that is
nirwana that is Ultimate salvation from
the cycle of birth death and rebirth if
you have no deeds in which you can be
reborn you get
Moka now this philosophy they say that a
human being is born born
handicapped is born with diseases maybe
because in his previous birth he did
some evil Deeds therefore he been
punished in this world so this
philosophy came up to justify that
almighty God cannot be unjust but if you
read the vdas nowhere do the vdas speak
about the cycle of birth death and
rebirth nowhere do they
speak nowhere in the vdas is the concept
of samsar
there what it does mention is the pun J
punar in Sanskrit means next or again
and Janam means birth so pun Jan means
next birth or next life the right
translation of pun Janam is next life it
doesn't mean Life Death Life Death life
that doesn't mean cycle of death and
life pun Janam if you translate Sanskrit
into English it means next life so vas
have got no problem in agreeing next
life and if you read the vdas r book
number 10 number 16 verse number 4.5 it
speaks about the next life that there is
a next life but doesn't speak about
death and life death and life and the
VAS also speak about SW that is Paradise
describing that there is Rivers flowing
beneath of milk you'll have all kinds of
fruit you'll have peace in SW in several
places in Atara book number two at book
number four book number six r book
number 10 sever places r even speaks
about Nar that is Hell describing
somewhat like a fire a torment of fire
for
punishment in several places in r book
number four so if the concept of SW and
Nar is there that after a person dies he
will get a reward and Punishment so what
is the requirement of him to come again
in this world so according to the vas
the vas believe in next life only once
and there depending upon your Deeds you
will either go to Paradise SW or Nar
that is
hell it doesn't believe in the concept
of birth death and rebirth which most of
the common Hindus belief and regarding
the logical reply why almighty God makes
some people handicapped some people
healthy will discuss in the concept of
life after the in
Islam in
Islam Allah says in the Quran in Surah
Bak chapter number two verse number 28
that don't you have faith seeing that
Allah gave you life when you didn't have
life
then he caused you to die then again
he'll give you life and to him will you
return Allah says in M chapter number 6
verse number
two it is Allah who has created death
and life to test which of you is good in
Deeds Allah says in Surah Imran 3: 185
that every soul shall have a taste of
death but the final recompence will be
on the day of judgment and anyone who
safe from the Hellfire and enters Jenna
the garden he has achieved the objective
of this world for this life is nothing
but mere chapters of play and amusement
so here according to Islam a human being
comes in this world only once and this
life is a test for the
Hereafter and depending how well you
follow the Commandments of almighty God
or you don't follow commandment of
almighty God based on that in the next
life in the
yearafter depending which ways more you
will either go to to Heaven that is
Paradise or hell that is n and the
description of Paradise
jna in Arabic jna translated as Garden
is given in replace in the Quran and the
concept is similar that there are rivers
flowing beneath rivers of milk and honey
fruits of all kind you'll have
pomegranates you will have peace there
will not be any sin Quran also talks
about hell about Janam similar to the
Vas as torment of Hell whose fuel will
be men and Stones Sur Bak 2 verse number
23 24 and many places the Quran even
speaks about Hellfire so the concept of
hell and heaven in Islam is somewhat
similar to the concept given in the vas
and if you read the
vas it is similar to the Islamic concept
that you come in this world once and
next life depending upon your Deeds upon
your karma next World you'll either go
to Hell or Heaven but it disagrees with
the common philosophy with the Hindu
Scholars talk about the
samsara the reason they came up with
this philosophy of samsara as I told you
they could not logically justify that
how could almighty God make some people
born in a rich family some in a poor
family some are born healthy some are
born with conal defect The Logical reply
for this is given in the Quran Allah
says in the
Quran in Sur an kabut chapter number 29
verse number
two that do you think just by saying I
believe Allah will let you go and Allah
will not test you that even if you say
that I believe in God do you think Allah
will not test you you are bound to be
tested every human being is bound to be
tested Allah says Allah says in Surah
Bak chapter number two verse number 155
that surely we will test you with fear
and with Hunger with loss of property
loss of lives loss of fruits of your
Toil and only those will pass
those who are patient and perseverance
that means almighty God will test you
with Hunger with fear with loss in
property in health in different things
Allah says in Surah anfal chapter number
8 verse number 28 that your wealth and
your progeny is a test for you the
wealth and the progeny your children are
a test for you so in Islam we believe
that this life is a test for the
Hereafter and Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
test different people people in
different ways and depending upon the
surroundings and the facility Allah
gives you he will test you accordingly
for example if the question paper is
difficult the teacher corrects the paper
leniently if the question paper is easy
the teacher corrects the paper most
strictly so similarly depending upon the
facility Allah has given you he will
test you accordingly and Allah says in
Surah anfal chapter 8 verse number 28
that your wealth is a test for you now
regarding the logical concept why some
people are born in a rich family some
people in a poor family Allah says
wealth is a test for
you the third pillar of Islam is every
rich person who has a saving of more
than the nisab level 85 grams of gold he
or she should give 2.5% of that saving
in charity every L
year so maybe very few rich people will
actually give the 2.5% of the excess
wealth in charity majority may give only
part of it
so in charity they'll get less marks
some people will not give so they'll get
zero marks for a poor man who has a
saving of less than 85 grams of gold he
doesn't have to give zakat so in zakat
he get full
marks we think ah
b poor
man Allah says wealth is a test for you
and a prophet said it is difficult for a
rich man to enter
Jenna so wealth is a very difficult test
[Applause]
imagine in the year 2002 doing
examination a very difficult question
comes in the year 2003 doesn't come so
we should be happy good this question
didn't come we should not cry but we
human being we think opposite you know
he doesn't have wealth he's a poor man
you know a sad person it is good for him
the difficult test of wealth he not
undergoing if he had the wealth the test
of the wealth is very difficult maybe
you would have failed so Allah test
different people in different way
regarding the reply why some people are
born healthy some people are born with
disease with conal heart defects Allah
says in Surah anfal chapter 8 verse 28
that your children are a test for you so
the person who's born even if he born
handicapped we in Islam believe every
child is mum is sinless we don't believe
that the child did some bad deeds in the
previous birth therefore he's born
handicapped we believe every child born
in any family he's sinless he's masum
but he may be a test for the parents the
parents may be Pious people may be
offering five times
Salah maybe Allah wants to test them
further and if Allah wants to give you a
great reward he has to test you in a
higher
level maybe for example if you sit for a
graduation in
arts to pass a ba degree in arts is easy
if you pass you become a graduate but to
pass an mbbs exam is more difficult but
if you pass you get doctor more honor
but the chances of passing mbbs is much
less but if you pass you get great honor
similarly maybe the parents they are ped
people almighty God wants to give them J
F Allah wants to test them that after
giving handicapped children yet do they
believe in almighty God or not so Allah
subhana tala tell different people with
health with disease with wealth with
poverty all these are test of Allah
subhana wa ta'ala and it is Allah subhah
wa ta'ala who tell different people in
different ways that's the reason there
are differences in the human being it is
not because almighty God is unjust he's
testing different people with different
ways and depending upon the facility he
has given you he will reward and punish
you
accordingly so this answers a logical
concept which the scholars could not
realize the sixth pillar of
is it Destiny in Hinduism also the
believe that almighty God
destines things in the human being and
similarly in Islam We Believe almighty
God has destined where a person is born
when will he
die Etc and whether he'll be born a rich
family or a poor family it is the
prerogative of the teacher to set the
question paper what question she wants
she will give you and you have to answer
accordingly you cannot say okay I don't
want this question I want that question
so Allah subhana distin people with
certain things where you'll be born when
you'll be born you'll have wealth or not
whether you'll have health or poverty
when you'll die and after this has been
distin whether do you follow the
Commandments given by almighty God in
the final Revelation that is a test for
the Hereafter this known as test this
was in brief regarding the pillars of IM
in Islam and the similarities in
Hinduism time will not permit us to
discuss the various similarities we'll
just discuss a few other similarities
which are not
known by the common Muslims and the
Hindus that exist in both the
religions Allah says in the Quran in Sur
MAA chapter number five verse number 90
Allah
says oh you
believe most certainly intoxicant and
gambling dedication of stones ration of
arrows
these are Satan's
handwork abstain from this handwork that
you may Prosper here Allah is telling us
that in toxicant gambling fortune
telling idol worship these are Satan's
handwork abstain from this handiwork
that you may
Prosper these
messages are also repeated in the Hindu
scriptures if you read Manus
smiti chapter number
n verse number 235
it prohibits the drinking of alcohol it
says that a priest
killer a liquor
Drinker a thief a violator of his guru's
marriage bed all these four people and
individually they commit major
sins and few verses later Manus chapter
number n verse number 238 gives the
punishment for these people it says that
these miserable men
no one should eat with them no one
should sacrifice for
them no one should read to them no one
should marry them they should wander
throughout the Earth excommunicated from
all the
religions the punishment for having
alcohol in Hinduism is that no one
should eat with him no one should read
to him no one should sacrifice for him
no one should marry him he should be
excommunicated from all the religions
and wander throughout the Earth even
this punishment is not mentioned in
Islam for a liquor Drinker next it
further says in maniti chapter number 11
verse number
55 it
says
that a
drinker a priest killer a person who
steals a person who
violates his guru's marriage bed all
these people and all those who associate
with him they commit major sinan not
only if you drink if you associate with
the dunard according to Manus smiti
chapter number 11 verse number 55 you
doing a major sin Manus smiti chapter
number 11 verse number 94 says that
liquor has been derived from the dirt
from the excreta of rice and dirt is
evil so a
priest nor a ruler nor a commoner should
drink liquor there are various place in
the Hindu scripture where Lia has been
prohibited including maniti chapter
number 9 verse number 225 manusi chapter
number 7 verse 47 manusi chapter number
7 verse number 50 rig book Number 8
himym number two verse number 12 r book
Number 8 himym number 21 verse number 14
in several places alcohol liquor has
been prohibited in the Hindu
scriptures now second Point mentioned
Sur chapter number 5 vers number 19
was most and gambling
Hindu scriptures even prohibit gambling
if you read r book number 10 himym
number 34 Verse number three it says a
gamster a gambler he says that his wife
leaves him aloof his mother hates him
and he says that no one Comforts this
Wretched Man and after a few verses r
book number 10 himm number 34 Verse
number 13 it says that do not play with
dice
rather cultivate the land and whatever
you earn be satisfied with that
earning gambling has also been
prohibited in maniti chapter number 7
verse number 50 it says drinking
gambling woman and hunting all these are
four major sins in
order drinking alcohol has also been
prohibited in maniti chapter number 7
verse number 47 in maniti chapter number
9 verse number 221 to 228 it's also
prohibited in manusi chapter number 9
verse number
258 the third
thing dedication of stone ration of
arrows ID worship we already discussed
earlier divination of arrows fortune
telling it's mentioned in maniti chapter
number n verse number 258 that a person
who earns his living by telling good
things a suser and a fortune
teller 9 verse 262 says that the king
shall punish them according to the
severity of the crime so even fortune
telling and suit saying has been
prohibited in Manus smiti chapter number
9 verse number 258 to
262 Quran further says in Surah Bak
chapter number 2 verse 188 Quran
prohibits bribing Quran
says use not your wealth as a bait for
the judges in order you may eat other
people's wealth Quran prohibits
involving in
Pride the same thing is mentioned in
manusi chapter number 9 verse number 258
it says that a person who deals with
bribe a deceiver a
defaulter all of them verse 262 says
that the king shall punish them
according to the severity of the
sin furthermore Quran prohibits the
eating of pork in no less than four
different places Allah says in the Quran
inah Bak chapter number 2 verse 173 ma
chter number 5 verse number 3 chter
number 6 verse number 145 and chter
number 16 verse number
115 for for you for food are dead meat
blood the Flesh of swine and any food on
which any name besides Allah's name is
invoked Quran prohibits besides other
things
the eating of the Flesh of swine porke
has been prohibited porke has also been
prohibited in the Hindu
scriptures it's mentioned in
maniti chapter number five verse number
19 it says that Abraham knowingly if he
eats mushroom if he eats dangi pig if he
eats onion a team or garlic he
shall
fall it's further mentioned in the
Vishnu
Sutra chapter number five verse number
49 that anyone who s spoke should be
punished in the same way anyone who
sells the Forbidden meat including pork
he should be punished in the same way
that means his opposite hands and legs
should be lopped
off the Vishnu
Sutra chapter number five verse number
49 says if anyone says pooke the
punishment for him is chopping off his
opposite hands and feet even this
punishment not mentioned in the Quran so
the Hindu scriptures are more
against not having the Flesh of Pok as
compared to Islamic
scriptures there are many misconception
in Islam and people always point a
finger that why does Islam subjugate
domain by keeping in the
whale and if you
Analyze That who is to decide what is
modest the Quran says in Sur n chapter
number 24 verse number 13 say to the
believing man that he should lower his
gaze and guard his
modesty that whenever a man looks at a
woman any breath and thought come in his
mind he should lower his gaze next verse
Sur n chapter number 24 verse number 31
says say to the believing woman that she
should lower a gaze and guard her
modesty and display not a beauty except
what appears ordinary of and draw her
whale over the bosom and displine of
beauty except in front of her father her
husband her son then a big list of mam
is given basically there are six
criteria for hijab which is given in the
the Quran and the Hadith the first is
the extent for the man from NE to the
knee for the woman the complete body
should be covered the only part that can
be seen are the face and hands up to the
wrist there are many scholars who say
that when they should be covered the
remaining five criteria are the same the
second is the clothes they wear it
should not be tight so that reveals the
figure third it should not be
transparent fourth it should not be So
Glamorous so that it attracts opposite
sex fifth it should not resemble and be
a sign of the unbeliever and sixth it
should not resemble that of the opposite
sex similar Hindu
scriptures it's mentioned in r book
Number 8 himm number 33 verse number 19
it says Brahma has made you a Dame made
you a lady so therefore cast down your
eyes and do not look up put your feet
together and let not your garment reveal
what your Veil
conceals so according to R book Number 8
himn number
33 verse number 19 it says that the the
woman should lower the Gaze they should
not stay at the opposite sex and they
should wear a
veil F mentioned in r book number 10
himn number 85 verse number 30
that it is devilish and not right when a
husband he covers his tis with the
garments of his wife that means wearing
clothes of opposite sex is prohibited in
Hinduism it's further mentioned
in mahavir
charit act number two page number 71
when SRI Ram when he
sees pararam he tells his wife sitha
that pararam he is our Elder you cast
thy eyes and draw the veil so Shri Ram
tells his wife SAA that when the Elder
comes you should draw the veil and look
down further if you read the books of
historical records we find the Indian
ladies many of them wear veils there are
coins in the post Gupta age showing
women Indian women wearing a veil and
the veil coming up to the shoulders some
up to the arms even today if you go in
many Indian villages we find that women
they cover the head some of them even
cover their face so here if you analyze
the modesty level of women in Islam and
Hinduism is the same that they have to
be covered
up furthermore people
talk about that why does Islam allow a
man to have more than one
wife in fact if you analyze most of the
major scriptures they permit a man to
marry as many wives as they
wish if you read Ram the father of Rah
King Dash he had three
wives if you read the Vishnu Sutra
chapter number 24 verse number one it
says a Brahman can have four wives if
you read Mahabharat Krishna had how many
wives four 10,000 10,000 Krishna had
16,18
wives so when Krishna can have 16,18
wives so why can't we Muslims have at
least
four Quran says in Surah NAA chapter
number four verse number three marry
woman of a choice in twos threes or
fours but if you can't do justice marry
only one in Islam you're allowed to
marry two three or four but if you can't
do justice you can only marry one but if
you can do justice the maximum you can
marry is only four you cannot marry
beyond that and the reason Islam allows
polyam me you can refer to my video
cassette women's rights in
Islam in the conclusion of my
talk I would like to mention that if we
analyze from
history that the britishers when they
came to India the Western philosophy it
influenced the Indian culture and
because of that the Indian culture was
going down and towards the starting of
the 19th century we have several Hindu
reformers the Pioneer amongst them is
Raja Raman Roy who was born in Bengal in
1772 he learned English Arabic and
Persian and he wrote a book in 183 which
spoke against idol worship he believed
in the philosophy of the
upanishads that believed universalism of
upanishad and he said that almighty God
is one he has got no images he spoke
against idol worship and said almighty
God did not have aars he cannot become a
human being he even spoke against cast
system and when he formed his trust the
Brahma he mentioned his trust deed he
mentioned the trust deed that no graven
image no carving No sculpture no statue
no picture no portrait will enter in
this building and there were many
offshoots of Brahma samage but all of
them believe in the same philosophy God
is one God has got no images idol
worship is wrong God does not become AAR
they against the K system as far as the
cycle of samsara was concerned it was
optional you want to follow follow don't
want to follow don't follow one among
the opsh of Brahma
samaj was prna samaj which was founded
by justice zanard justice zanard in Brom
founded the prna samage and there he
followed all these principle but was
strictly for the upliftment of the woman
and said that the woman should be
educated and a woman who becomes the
widow she should
remarry the other great reformer that we
had was Swami Dan sarasti who founded
the Arya s in
875 he believed strickly in the vas and
he said that the Hindus should follow
only the vas and he strictly said that
God is one God has got no
images he spoke against idol worship he
said God Almighty doesn't have
aars the other great reformer that most
of us aware is Swami vianda who founded
ramakrishan Mission and he too spoke
that we should follow The Vedas and he
said though 99% of the vas have been
lost today we have only 1% of The Vedas
which cannot be accommodated even in a
large Hall but he said that we should
not call ourselves Hindus we should call
ourselves vedantist follow the vas now
if we analyze that the
britishers came a few centuries ago to
India to do business but unfortunately
they looted our
country and they had the policy of
divide and
Rule and they saw to it that they were
differen between the Hindus and Muslims
so that they could rule and they even
corrupted many of the Indian culture
because of that Hinduism went down and
that's the reason that in the early part
of 19th century there was The Surge of
Hindu
reformers like rajar Ram Roy like Jus
anady whatever I spoken in my talk all
have been picked up from these great
Scholars
I am just a student of comparative
religion all these things have spoken of
Hinduism is not my own invention all
these have been picked up from these
great Hindu reformers like rajar Ram
mroy like justice
anade I have only as a student of
compared religion I verified it and what
I did whatever they spoke the references
wer given I went to the Hindu scriptures
and I give the references only thing I
did was I did the references nothing
else
and all the things I mention about
Hinduism it was always backed up with
quotation from The Vedas and the other
Hindu scriptures I'm aware vas are the
most authentic but the reason I've given
quotation from the other scriptures also
because many Hindus those who believe
only in Vedas even if they remove all
the other quotations besides The Vedas
yet my talk will be 100% the same but
there are many Hindus though they
respect The Vedas but they are more well
aware of bhagat gaita and the puranas so
because of that I've quoted these
scriptures also so that they can come
closer to The Vedas and come closer to
the concept which is established in the
Hindu
scripture the britishers they had the
policy of divide and Rule and
unfortunately even I fell pray to that I
thought how could Hinduism have
similarities with Islam impossible after
reading books of these great Scholars
these great reformers and doing research
that's how this talk has come about but
the main reason that these britishers
they had the policy of divide and Rule
our country has got the freedom from the
britishers but unfortunately yet we are
slaves to the policy of divide and
[Music]
Rule and unfortunately most of our
Indian
politicians if not all most of them they
follow the same rule of divide and Rule
to get their
votes India's a country in the world
which has the maximum number of Rights
every day we have more than one right on
our
average and if you go to the background
of these rights almost all of these
rights have been engineered by
politicians for the V
bank there was somebody who told me that
the politicians they add fuel to the
fire I told them no he's wrong I don't
agree that the politicians add fuel to
the fire the politicians they add fire
to the fuel
[Applause]
the fuel most of the time is
constructive you know the vehicles run
with fuel factories are working the fuel
makes the construction of a country they
add fire to it and they cause
destruction of the country there was an
article that came last month in times of
India and Bombay it says that according
to Japan in the next 20 years India will
be the superpower of the
world we know that before the britishers
came to India India was a superpower
now if all the Indians all the Hindus
and all the Muslims if you go back to
our scriptures and follow the
established truth of the scriptures
believing in one God beli in the final
messenger believing life after death
inshallah India will be a superpower
[Applause]
only if all the Indians the Hindus and
the Muslims if you go back to the
scripture and follow the scriptures
we'll be a super power will be far
superior to the Americans far superior
to America and the European countries
[Applause]
inshallah it is clearly mentioned in the
vas Riga tells us in book number 10
himym number 71 verse number four seeing
the words they see not hearing the words
they hear not you see it mention the
scripture so clearly yet you see not you
hear the words of the scripture yet you
hear not same thing the Quran says in
Sur Bak chapter number 2 verse number 44
you study the scripture yet you don't
follow it Allah says in Bak chter number
2 verse number
18 form Arun the deaf the dumb the blind
they will not the true part we feel and
we see that most of the religious
leaders of most of the major religion
whether it be Islam Christianity or
Hinduism they prevent the followers from
reading the scripture with
understanding for their own ulterior
benefits because if the followers read
the scriptures then maybe they will not
be able to get the alterior benefits I
have given the talk earlier on the topic
alquran should it be with understanding
if we understand Quran the best way to
understand is to learn Arabic as a
language if you cannot learn Arabic as a
language read the translation of the
Quran in the language you understand the
best and we have the Quran translated in
the major languag of the world similarly
if you analyze that though there are
many sects in Islam there are many sex
but the differences that are there in
the sex are very
small are very minute they're negligible
the major factor of all these sects of
Islam they are the same that almighty
God is one that the Quran is the same
that the messenger of mhammad sallallahu
Ali wasallam is the same because the
reason is the language in which the
Quran was revealed the last and final
Revelation the Glorious Quran
the language was Arabic and today yet
Arabic is a living
language that's the reason WIlliam Mo
Sir William Mo was a ston Critic of
Islam yet he mentioned that the book
that has maintained Purity in the past
12 centuries he said 20 years ago is the
Glorious
Quran because it was revealed in a
language Arabic which is a living
language my request to the Indian
government and to my dear Hindu brothers
and sisters is
that you should revive Sanskrit it's my
humble request to the Indian government
and my Hindu brothers and sisters you
learn Sanskrit go back to your
scriptures go back to your Vedas and
realize that God is
[Applause]
one you understand that God has got no
images you understand God has got no AAR
you should understand and realize who's
the last and final messenger you should
understand this life is a test for the
Hereafter and then only we Muslims and
Hindus can come together and build a
great Indian
Nation I would like to end my talk with
the quotation of the Glorious Quran of
Surah yunus chapter number 10 ver
108 say oh humankind truth has arrived
from your lord those who receive
guidance they do good for their own
souls and those who go astray they do it
at their own loss I have not been set up
as a manager of a phth over youhd
[Applause]
[Music]